it just comes natural it's like a
maturity thing travis barker is giving
us an
inside look on why he and girlfriend
kourtney kardashian
may be meant to be it's amazing on
thursday the blink 182 drummer appeared
on the drew barrymore show
and revealed that having kids is what
makes their relationship
so easy he also admitted that dating
someone who doesn't have kids
has been a struggle in the past our
neighbor
and friend travis barker decided to come
over
to chloe's house because his kids and my
kids are really good friends
courtney is the mom to three children
eleven-year-old mason eight-year-old
penelope
and six-year-old reign while travis is
the father of seventeen-year-old landon
and fifteen-year-old alabama i find it
kind of
hard because they would i think they
would have trouble understanding like
well why
why don't you want to go to dinner every
night with me or why don't you want to
see me every night
and now i'm
you know spending time with a woman
who's like a great mom
another thing that keeps their
relationship going being able to miss
each other
and i also really like missing someone
and and
cherishing the time that i spend with
them instead of you know every day being
with them
or especially in the beginning of the
relationship
i i think like missing someone so
important travis also took time to
cherish courtney's love note he posted
via
instagram writing quote to lots of fun
adventures
maybe destroy each other completely i
would prefer to
you know kind of go in a blaze of glory
like ball of flames a source confirmed
to et last month that the couple started
dating after having a platonic
relationship for years
until recently something sparked the two
also went instagram official on
valentine's day by snapping
this photo i'm just like living life and
whatever happens happens
[Music]